über sieben Frauen wurden jetzt in einer
Stadt betatscht nur einem Wochenende
sollen mindestens sieben Mädchen unter
Wasser begrabscht worden sein eine Flut
ein Videos sie sollen Schlägereien
Randale und sexuellen Missbrauch zeigen
scheinbar überall in Deutschland
scheinbar permanent trauriger Höhepunkt
und Symbol der Gewalt das kolumbierbad
in Berliner Stadtteil Neukölln immer
wieder kam es hier zu Ausschreitungen
und Übergriffen nach einem Brandbrief
der Mitarbeiter wurde das Bad
geschlossen
die ist nicht zulässig
die müssen da rausholen das geht nicht
er ist hier der Chef sein Job alles im
Blick behalten für Sicherheit sorgen in
und am Becken
wir sind eigentlich normalerweise nicht
dafür da dass wir Idioten oder
Vollpfosten dementsprechend ständig
ermahnen müssen was sie nicht zu tun
haben und dass sie uns den ganzen
Badebetrieb durcheinander bringen und
das ist glaube ich im Moment ist das
Problem Land auf und Land ab das einfach
zu viel Aggressivität in den Bädern ist
respektlos gegen auch das Personal
vorgegangen wird unter der Woche ist es
hier ruhig doch ein heißen Wochenende
wenn das Bad mit 5000 Besuchern voll ist
kippt immer wieder die Stimmung
wir haben danach Mittag schon drei vier
Mal die Polizei dann da weil ihn auch
die Widersetzung gegen die Security da
ist und das ist alles sehr nervig es
sind vor allem junge Männer zwischen 14
und 30 die Erde machen erzählt Jörg
Augenstein viele von ihnen mit
Migrationsgeschichte
das extremste ist immer dass du relativ
schnell als Rassist hingestellt wirst
wenn du was
durchziehen möchtest es hat aber mit
rassistischen Sachen gar nichts zu tun
weil sie verhalten sich einfach nicht
dementsprechend was den Baderegeln der
Haus und Badeordnung entspricht junge
Männer die sich nicht an Regeln halten
das beobachtete gewaltforscher Dirk
Bayer aber nicht nur bei Jugendlichen
mit Migrationsgeschichte von
migrantischer Gewalt reden sondern am
ist natürlich schon Gewalt junge
Menschen und hier insbesondere junge
Männer und das ist in Freibädern aber
nicht anders auch als in anderen
Kontexten im öffentlichen Raum haben wir
es meistens wenn wir über physische
Gewalt sprechen mit Gewalt von jungen
Männern zu tun eine Einschätzung die
auch Zahlen der Polizeilichen
Kriminalstatistik Baden-Württemberg
belegen von insgesamt 590
Tatverdächtigen in Freibädern hatten 386
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft die
größten Gruppen unter den nicht
deutschen Tatverdächtigen bildeten
syrische türkische
französische Staatsangehörige
gegen die Unruhe Stifter in seinem
Freibad brauche es dringend mehr
Hausverbote fordert er doch die seien
schwer durchzusetzen und für strengere
Kontrollen fehlt das Personal
wenn wir also dementsprechend Taschen
kontrolliert haben hier auf dem Gelände
wenn Vorfälle waren ja da ist auf einmal
ein Messer drin gewesen oder eine
Steinschleuder oder sonst irgendwas das
ist natürlich was brauche ich hinten ein
großes Messer hier im Freibad hat hier
nichts zu suchen unter der Woche finden
die Besucher hier Erholung und Abkühlung
die aufgeheizte Stimmung an den
Wochenenden meiden die meisten aber
bewusst
komm gerne her Wochenende lasse ich aus
weil er ist mir dann zu voll
oder irgendwas manchmal Samstag Sonntag
zu viel da ist es über voll und das sind
sehr viele Jugendliche und Security dann
kommt Polizei und es sich dann nicht
schön gerade ist ja auch die Diskussion
von wegen oben ohne z.B im Freibad das
würde ich mich jetzt hier zum Beispiel
ihren Licht trauen wenn es mal angeln
rein in dem Schwimmbecken gibt finde das
gehört bei Jugendlichen auch mal dazu
haben bestimmt auch
die eine oder andere Regel gebrochen
aber irgendwo hatten wir trotzdem noch
ein moralischen Kompass und ich glaube
der fehlt so ein bisschen
wir sind Stuttgarter Respekt nutzen und
wir reden über Respekt mit jungen
Menschen wie wichtig ist für euch
Respekt nicht wichtig nicht wichtig
vielen der Respekt das begegnet Kevin
Burka im Freibad häufig er koordiniert
38 Jugendliche die ehrenamtlich im
ganzen Stadtgebiet unterwegs sind das
Ziel Respekt zeigen und einfordern damit
es erst gar nicht zu Gewalt kommt wir
merken dass sich Menschen Respekt
wünschen nicht alle geben Respekt aber
es ist so wenn man den Impuls reingibt
kommt das zurück entstanden ist das
Projekt vor zwei Jahren nach
Ausschreitungen hier im Stuttgarter
Inselbad heute ist Kevin Gurke mit samei
und Sabi unterwegs beide kamen vor
sieben Jahren als Flüchtlinge aus
Afghanistan kennen die Lebensrealität
und Sprache viele Besucher die Gewalt in
Freibädern wollen sie nicht einfach
hinnehmen
versuchen wir das alle möglichen
wenigstens dass das kein Schlägerei gibt
und ja dass die Leute nur Spaß haben
doch auch hier kam es in diesem Jahr
schon mehrfach zu sexuellen Übergriffen
insbesondere Hieber und Elena hören
immer wieder dass ich viele Frauen hier
nicht respektiert fühlen
gerade von jüngeren Mädchen so zwischen
16 und 18 bekommen wir sehr oft
Rückmeldungen dass sie sich eben unwohl
fühlen weil sie oft mitbekommen dass es
eben Ausschreitungen gab das
Belästigungen gab die Zahl der
Straftaten in baden-württembergischen
Freibädern ist zwar im Vergleich zu 2019
auf den niedrigsten Stand seit acht
Jahren gesunken doch gleichzeitig sind
Fälle von Rohheitsdelikten und
Straftaten gegen die persönliche
Freiheit deutlich angestiegen dazu
zählen unter anderem Körperverletzung
Raub oder Nötigung
die meisten Freibäder und Deutschland
sind weiterhin friedlich da gibt es
keine Probleme
aber ich denke es ist richtig dass das
einzuordnen und festzustellen wir haben
ein Stück weit in Gewalt Problem wieder
unter Jugendlichen in Deutschland und
das ist ein klein wenig Ausdruck auch
dafür von gewalttätigen Vorfällen haben
auch diese drei Freundinnen gehört ins
Freibad gehen sie dennoch gerne
ich fühl mich insgesamt sicherer ich
wenn man mit Freunden ist glaube ich
dann alleine wäre es vielleicht jetzt
noch mal was anderes die drei
Freundinnen sind heute zum ersten Mal im
Inselbad für viele andere Besucher sind
die respektlosen mittlerweile vertraute
Gesichter
also kommen heute auch Leute auf uns zu
einem Teil wir sehen euch hier wir sehen
uns in den blauen T-Shirts und ich will
wissen das respektlosen und du kannst
schon was darunter vorstellen und wir
fokussieren uns auch darauf im Gespräch
eine leicht immer wieder darauf
hinzuweisen falls was ist kommt auf uns
zu ihre Präsenz habe sich bereits
positiv auf die Stimmung im Inselbad
ausgewirkt betont die Stadt Stuttgart
zudem wurde das Sicherheitspersonal
verdoppelt
ich glaube es ist gut zunächst in der
proaktiven und auch in der Prophylaxe
zusammenzuarbeiten mit den respektlosen
auf Augenhöhe aber gleichzeitig sicher
zu gehen und zu sagen wir stocken das
Sicherheitspersonal auf um überhaupt zu
vermeiden dass es so weit kommt und
deshalb sind Kevin Gurke und seine
Kollegen hier auch weiterhin unterwegs
für ein respektvolles Miteinander nicht
nur im Freibad